this is kier's opportunity to set out a
vision for the country because of the
pandemic uh 18 months into the job this
is his first opportunity to do that he
will be talking about the party being a
winning party he'll be talking about the
future he'll draw on his background and
present himself of course to the country
and i think that there are some exciting
proposals on mental health on climate
and on education that we'll see
in a few hours time looking forward to
it of course we'll be covering it and
carrying that speech here on sky news um
we also saw um jeremy corbyn was there
uh yesterday holding court um do you
wish he hadn't come
look i mean i
anyone can come to our to our fringe um
but i've got to say
jeremy corbyn
is the past we lost the general election
we lost decisively very sadly we're down
to the worst number of mps since 1935.
kier's job has been of course to rebuild
our party but to earn the british
people's trust
and to put us in a place where we can
win a general election instead of
consistently losing one so uh i'm
interested in the end in what kierstama
is saying this afternoon the british
people will certainly be interested in
that and they will tune in they will
watch the clips so this is a hugely
important moment for us
yeah and we'll move on in just a second
but as far as secure is concerned he was
very loyal to jeremy corbyn when he was
leader he must be annoyed that that the
former leader is coming in and trying to
steal his thunder
look i i
i don't think he's bothered i mean he's
as cool as a cucumber to be honest you
know conference has been
bumpy at the start of course it has as
he's had to recalibrate the party to be
outward focused and not inward focused
and there is a sense in which a
conference particularly at the beginning
you're negotiating in public it's on tv
the debates that's being had on the con
conference floor but in the end what
we've had is we've had rachel reeves
setting out they're going to be fiscally
responsible
talking about business rates we've had
ed miliband setting out a bold vision on
climate raising 28 billion green
investment all that we've got to do so
we haven't got the energy crisis that
we've currently got i set out some
proposals yesterday on justice alongside
nick thomas simmons that in the end is
where we have to be the bread and butter
issues and boy we've got an
extraordinary time to be doing this
people unable to fill up their cars with
petrol shortages and skills right across
the country being an issue this is an
opportunity for the labour party to
demonstrate we understand those costs of
living issues and we want to talk about
the key issues that will move this
country forward leon you've got angela
rainer calling people scum
well that that's a sideshow i mean often
journalists focus on
um the individuals and the characters in
the end i mean that would be just listen
the reason i mentioned it mr lammy is
because you were listing some of the
characters um who are front and center
none more so than ms rainer and then she
calls people scum i mean can you defend
that
uh i don't want to get into it to be
honest okay what i want to talk about
because because kay what matters today
is kirsten speech mental health matters
education of our children matters it
does
it has to be a party that's the climate
the climate the climate's emergency
matters well look i've been accused over
the years of strong language in relation
to my opponents uh but in the end it's
the substance of policies that will
determine the result of the next general
election and to be honest i really don't
think the labour party need to take
lectures from a conservative party with
a leader that said some terrible things
about all sorts of people he called
people like me people with watermelon
smiles and pikanini so look all sorts of
things have been said in politics but
let's focus on the plan we've got a
government that hasn't got a plan it's
important that labour lays one out for
the british people absolutely outrageous
that he would say something like that
and of course we've held him
to account and he talked about uh women
in burkas looking as though they were
letterboxes i mean
all of that is racist surely
well you know that's that's how i define
it but in the end again i don't think
these issues around identity are in the
end the substance of what the british
people need at this time they can't get
fuel which means that many of them can't
get to work
supplies are short in the shops what
kind of christmas are we going to have
gas supplies are going up taxes are
going up with national insurance
those are the key and critical issues
what's happening to our children who've
fallen behind that's where the labour
party has to be with a plan of action
the british people can trust that's
responsible that's what kierstammer has
to set out that's his mission and yes
there's noise around the sides and there
are issues around identity and other
things but i'm afraid that's not where
the central action is and it's a
distraction for him to get drawn up in
that yeah but it's a distraction of of
your own making as a party mr mummy i
mean you are an incredibly popular mp
you are the most
popular mp sitting in the chamber you've
got a bigger majority i think than any
other mp certainly you had at the at the
last election
and you know
that personality is really important
when it comes to politics that's how
tony blair got elected it's not very
often that labor gets elected and you
need to be able to identify with the
public in order for that to happen and
what you don't need is the second in
command um calling people scum
i mean look in all my years in politics
i remember
john prescott would sometimes say
fruity things i remember norman tebbett
would sometimes say
uh challenging things that i certainly
disagreed with that that that that has
come and gone in politics
and it's a talking point for a day or
two
but in the end what determines who will
form a government is a set of policies
okay that's the point that i'm making
yeah but can we at least agree then
can we at least agree
that we're being told by the labour
party and indeed the conservatives that
we're looking for kind of politics
that surely in the 21st century given
what we've been through as a society
over the last 18 months
we need to be kinder to each other
yeah i'd agree with that kate that's a
nice way of putting it we do need to be
kinder to each other so i'd agree with
that yeah
okay what about andy mcdonald doing what
he did with the leader and and coming
down to party conference and resigning
that's taking away again from the
leaders thunder you know if you've got
an open girl you've been talking about
fuel uh issues and and gas prices etc
etc and then he goes to and resigns in
the middle of party conference not
helpful
look andy mcdonald did very good work
with angela ramer on our employment
policies and we set out a plan at
conference i was very sad to see andy
resign in the way
that he did
it's important that we're clear about a
minimum wage and we've said that it's a
minimum of 10 pounds but we have to be
fiscally responsible and i think
there'll be lots of small businesses out
there that are saying we've been
struggling for the last year and a jump
from 8 pounds 91 an hour
to 15 pounds is not something that we
can withstand
so look i i recognize as a healthy
debate about what should be a minimum
wage because costs are rising and this
is hard uh on working people
i thank andy for all that he did i'm sad
that he left in the way he did but we
move forward because we have to move
forward as a party responsive to the
british people
talking about policy how we how are we
going to get more hgv drivers to sort
out this smart at this mess mr lammy do
you have a thought on that
well look in the end
in the short term we are going to need
more visas to get those drivers through
but we've got to be clear that the
decisions were made uh in relation to
um the brexit deal that does make it
unattractive to come to britain because
it's subject to terrorists now um and
often drivers are going back they're not
going back with goods because we haven't
we're no longer part of a customs union
alongside that there have been
long-standing skills gaps um in the
haulage industry that haven't been fixed
and those are issues that boris johnson
will have to address
in the coming days he's been hiding
what's he been doing he's now saying
that we're not going to have christmas
he said that last year as well so in the
end we've got to hold boris johnson to
account for the decisions that he and
others have made and the promises
they've made that have led us to this
mess and it's not just shortages of
lorry drivers we've got shortages of
fruit pickers and across agriculture
we've got shortages in building supplies
and finding builders to do the work
hence costs are going up right across
the country shortages in catering and in
our restaurants because we haven't got
the skills people have left so right
across the country there are skills gaps
and i suspect this will get bigger as a
consequence of decisions that boris
johnson made and the deal that he struck
actually i think he says that we will
have christmas um as opposed to not
having christmas but he did say that
this time last year as well so let's
wait and see what happens as far as
that's concerned um meantime let me ask
you um as far as policy maybe you can
just tell me about mental health i know
it's in the leader's speech so you can't
give me too much um but you're going to
be guaranteeing access to mental health
for people who need it
how much will it cost
and how will we pay for it
we're going to raise 1.7 billion by
a
business rate and v80 levy
on private schools and we've also set
out that we'll raise some further funds
uh in relation to v80 that's how we're
going to pay for it
okay finally before before i let you go
obviously looking forward to the leaders
speech today what's it like being back
by the seaside having um had a an
enforced time of not being able to get
together as a party
well look it's been phenomenal to
actually meet people
um again to see people there's a sense
in which we're getting back to to normal
it's been a lot of fun actually to be
here in brighton i'm sure that
conservative colleagues will say the
same at their conference in manchester
next week no i think it's good to see us
getting back to normal as a country in a
sense conference seasons represents that
and this whole current cycle okay and
you've been in politics a long time and
presenting a long time and being a
journalist for a long time we're getting
back to politics as normal after periods
in which one subject brexit and then the
pandemic dominated and so this has been
a breath of fresh air
something's just come to me mr lammy i
know i've got to let you go you've got a
million other things to do and i was
thinking about party conference bright
and i mean labour's natural home would
be more sort of black pool i suppose and
there's a bit of an issue with the
blackpool illumination some people are
very cross about some of the black
illuminations that have been up for
decades and decades and decades and now
they're feeling that they are um in some
way racist i don't know if you've been
reading about the issue
um in the paper some um native americans
saying that the red indian
illuminations are racist have you got a
view on that
i haven't got a view on that i'm afraid
um because i haven't seen the
illuminations
uh i've never seen the illuminations
well i can't remember them
it's not
it's not unusual is it okay for
us sometimes to revisit things that
we've done years ago that don't fit with
the current times i mean that comes up
time and time again it doesn't just come
up for minority communities it comes up
for women
as well so i don't know the specific
issues um
blackpool is a great city with great
people um it's a great place to visit um
that i do know and i hope that
conference is able to go back there
sometime in the future